quand j'étais au cm1 j'avais mis au
point un code secret absolument génial
pour communiquer l'idée c'était que dans
un message vous remplacer chaque lettre
par la lettre qui la suit dans
l'alphabet
voilà c'est tout et bien aujourd'hui on
va voir comment on peut faire beaucoup
beaucoup mieux que ça
évidemment l'idée de coder un message en
remplaçant chaque lettre par la suivante
n'est pas de moi elle est vieille comme
le monde on appelle ça le chiffrement
par décalage il paraît que césar
l'utilisait pour communiquer avec ses
généraux et d'ailleurs certains
appellent ça le code de césar sauf que
césar il avait été un tout petit peu
plus malin que moi puisque ils pouvaient
utiliser des décalages qui n'était pas
forcément d'une lettre mais qui pouvait
être deux trois lettres cette lettre ou
douze lettres
si césar voulait envoyer un message et
barry choisissait un décalage
et il suffisait que son destinataire
connaissent la valeur du décalage pour
reconstituer le message de départ mais
sur un code comme celui de césar et pas
très difficile à casser une fois que
vous connaissez le principe si jamais
demain vous intercepté un message de
césar et bien il suffit d'essayer tous
les décalages possible et il y en a que
25 jusqu'à trouver celui qui fonctionne
donc c'est pas un code très très solide
si vous voulez quelque chose de plus
robuste vous pouvez par exemple utiliser
le métal légèrement différente où vous
remplacer chaque lettre par une autre
lettre de l'alphabet mais pas forcément
issus d'un décalage c'est ce qu'on
appelle le chiffrement par substitution
si vous prenez un message qui a été codé
par substitution et que vous essayez de
le décoder en testant tous les codes
possible eh ben il ya beaucoup plus de
possibilités
on peut faire rapidement le calcul 1
pour coder la lettre à il ya vingt-six
possibilité pour la lettre b il en reste
25 pour la lettre ces 24 et c'est donc
le nombre total de code par substitution
possible
c'est ce qu'on appelle factorielle de 26
c'est un nombre absolument énorme
et juste pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée si vous étiez capable d'essayer
un million de code à chaque seconde
eh ben il vous faudrait quand même 13
mille milliards d'années pour l'essayer
tous c'est à dire mille fois l'âge de
l'univers donc avec des chiffres comme
ça on a envie de penser que les codes
par substitution sont absolument
impossible à casser et en fait c'est pas
vrai ils sont même assez facile à
craquer
pour comprendre comment on peut casser
facilement les textes qui sont codées
par substitution
on peut prendre un exemple donc là je
vous mets un message que j'ai codé avec
un certain code par substitution et il
ya une chose que vous pouvez observer
sur ce message c'est qu'il ya une lettre
qui revient assez souvent est d'ailleurs
assez souvent en fin de mot c'est la
lettre t et donc on a de bonnes raisons
de penser que la lettre t doit
certainement symboliser le e
et bien ce principe là on peut le
pousser beaucoup plus loin et faire ce
qu'on appelle de l'analyse des
fréquences vous regardez la fréquence
d'apparition des différentes lettres
dans le message et vous la comparez à la
fréquence d'apparition des lettres en
français et donc ça c'est quelque chose
de bien connu on sait que la lettre la
plus fréquente c'est le et ensuite c'est
le a et c est donc si vous connaissez la
langue d'origine du message est que ce
message est suffisamment long pour se
prêter à ce genre de l'analyse
statistique
eh ben on peut assez rapidement
grandement réduire le nombre de
possibilités a testé et il existe même
des algorithmes qui peuvent à eux tous
seuls quasiment casser un code par
substitution
vous voyez que la faiblesse du code par
substitution et qui fait qu'on peut
l'attaquer par analyse de fréquences
c'est le fait que une lettre donnée par
exemple eux va être toujours représenté
par la même lettre dans le message codé
existe des moyens d'éviter ça et on peut
utiliser par exemple une clé de
chiffrement donc le principe est le
suivant il vous faut choisir un mot clé
alors par exemple on va prendre le mot
science vous écrivez votre message et
sous votre message vous écrivez votre
mot clé autant de fois que nécessaire et
ensuite pour coder le message vous
ajouter chaque lettre du message à la
lettre du mot clé qui lui correspond
quand je dis que vous ajoutez les
lettres évidemment ce que vous faites
c'est que vous ajoutez leur position
dans l'alphabet et puis si jamais ça
dépasse 26 vous revenez à 0 et en
faisant ça vous obtenez un message codé
et vous pouvez observer que dans ce
message codé une lettre donnée par
exemple eux n'est pas toujours
représenté par la même lettre ait donc
grâce à ce procédé vous pouvez échapper
à la taxe par analyse de fréquences
alors pour que ça marche bien il faut
prendre une clé suffisamment longue là
j'ai juste pris un mot mais vous pouvez
très bien prendre une phrase voire
carrément un paragraphe en entier et
donc dans ces conditions ce genre de
code peut devenir quasiment inviolable
alors il ya juste un petit problème avec
ce type de code c'est que vous devez
donner la clé à quelqu'un pour qu'il
vous envoie des messages codés imaginons
que vous soyez une agence de services
secrets et que vous ayez des espions sur
le terrain
vous avez envie que ces espions vous
envoie des messages codés mais il ya un
petit risque c'est que si jamais ils se
font piquer la clé ou que la clé se fait
intercepter au moment où la transmettez
du coup l'ennemi peut décoder vos
messages la raison c'est que ce type de
code est ce qu'on appelle un code
symétrique c'est à dire que la clé pour
coder les messages est la clé pour les
décoder et ben c'est la même mais en
fait c'est pas du tout obligatoire dans
les années 70 om haïti à boston il ya
trois chercheurs en informatique qui ont
mis au point un système de cryptographie
qu'on appelle asymétrique c'est-à-dire
que la clé pour coder est la clé pour
décoder ne sont pas les mêmes c'est ce
qu'on appelle lé algorithme rsa du nom
des trois inventeurs alors l'algorithme
rsa je vais pas vous le décrire ici bon
il n'est pas extrêmement compliqué il ya
juste un peu de maths mais je vous
mettrais un lien dans la description
ce qui est intéressant de comprendre
c'est comment ça fonctionne pour faire
un codage selon l'algorithme rsa il faut
que vous choisissiez une clé et une clé
c'est un nom à leur apprendre par
exemple le nombre 143 donc il ya toute
une procédure et à partir de cette clé
vous fabriquez votre message codé le
truc c'est que pour décoder le message
il faut que la personne possède la
décomposition de ce nombre en facteur
premier donc dans le cas 243 c'est par
exemple 11 x 13 donc la clé de codage
ses 143
mais la clé de décodage ses 11 et 13
alors dans ce cas là c'est pas hyper
compliqué de retrouver la clé de
décodage
une fois qu'on connaît la clé de codage
puisque si je vous dis 143 vous pouvez
très bien trouver que c'est qu'on soit
13 mais si je m'amuse à prendre un
nombre beaucoup plus gros
eh bien là ça devient quasiment
impossible de retrouver sa décomposition
au facteur premier donc en pratique si
vous voulez utiliser l'algorithme rsa
qu'est ce que vous faites vous prenez
deux nombres premiers énorme voulait
multiplier entre eux et ça vous
fabriquez votre clé de codage cette clé
là vous pouvez la distribuer à peu près
n'importe qui d'ailleurs parfois on
appelle ça la clé publique
par contre les deux nombres premiers de
départ voulait garder pour vous c'est la
clé de décodage c'est ce qu'on appelle
la clé privée et donc grâce à ça des
gens partout peuvent vous envoyer des
messages qui vont pouvoir codé mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'ils pourront
décoder les messages des autres et donc
même si la clé fuite ou que l'ennemi
arrivent à s'en emparer
eh bien il n'y a aucun problème ils
pourront pas décodé vos messages alors
l'algorithme rsa aujourd'hui on trouve
un petit peu partout et il est même à la
base d'un grand nombre de protocoles de
communication sécurisé sur internet et
donc il ya une grande partie de la
sécurité informatique mondial et donc
probablement de l'instabilité de
l'économie qui repose sur des critères
de ce type et c'est quand même marrant
que tout ça tient une fille née au fait
que mathématiquement c'est compliqué de
trouver les facteurs premiers d'un
nombre et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que à
une certaine époque y en a qui
s'inquiétait de l'arrivée possible des
ordinateurs quantiques
parce qu'une des choses un ordinateur
quantique est censé faire beaucoup mieux
qu'un ordinateur classique c'est
factoriser des donc
et donc si demain quelqu'un se pointait
avec un ordinateur quantique
suffisamment puissant et ben ils
pourraient casser toutes les clés rsa et
donc ça foutrait probablement un beau
bordel
alors heureusement à ce jour je crois
que le plus gros nombre qu'un ordinateur
quantique et réussit à factoriser ses
143 donc qu'on soit 13 vous voyez qu'on
a encore un petit peu de tranquillité de
vendre merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur tout
pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne
vous pouvez vous abonner s'est pas déjà
fait aller voir mes vidéos précédentes
et me retrouver sur facebook sur twitter
et aussi sur mon blog sert elle science
étonnante
à bientôt